are you competitive and no and I'm more
if I'm in an argument i'm totally the
person was like no you're okay okay yeah
okay sorry I'm a huge apology I've
apologized about everything all the time
like sorry sorry um I played sports
growing up and no I think like if I saw
somebody else even when I score goal
better than me or want to do anything
like um I get past me or something it's
like oh no I think what pushover I just
I feel bad instantly and I'm not
competitive which is a very weird
business for me to be in but I think as
an actress you're only competing against
yourself what if someone's competitive
toward you you're not bringing it to
them but you can sense it and we've all
been in those situations yeah that's um
that's fine I think that comes from
their own insecurities whenever like if
I'm in an audition room and I know
people are trying to psych people at it
doesn't it doesn't do anything it
doesn't mean anything because they
should be focusing on their craft and
focusing on studying in their character
or just like relaxing and not trying to
psych other people that just shows that
that they're not happy with themselves
so I don't pay any energy to it
otherwise it'll just take me out of it
anyway so it means nothing
you